[Music]  are you ready to talk Ron oh yeah yeah  why wouldn't I be are you kidding most  horrifying six books of my life the cast  of American Horror Story Roanoke came  out to celebrate the show at PaleyFest  in LA on Sunday night she won every  award Sara Paul said when the stars hit  the stage for their panel Cuba Gooding  jr. and Sarah Paulson had an interesting  moment and this and this lady is just  yeah kuba played around with Sarah's  skirt a moment that came across a little  uncomfortable at another point he also  grabbed the arms of her chair and  dragged it and Sarah across the stage  but all these exchanges seemed to be in  fun just on Oh nobody needs to know  about it  the whole cast was in good spirits  during the panel giggling their way  through the hour-long sit-down  [Music]  you